what's going on guys this is rob welcome
back to geek culture explained and we
are talking about the re-release of
spider-man no way home the more fun
stuff or as we like to call it the
awkward and uncut version so for those
of you guys who don't know the
spider-man no way home film was recently
re-released to theaters with 11 minutes
of extra footage that we simply just
didn't see in the theatrical cut because
it was removed for any number of reasons
such is the case when it comes to
hollywood films now one of the cool
things that happens here is that you see
andrew and toby and tom all of whom are
on a zoom call basically thanking
everybody for supporting them now this
is not officially part of the movie it's
them as actors thanking all of us as
fans who supported the three of them
coming together for the film and
honestly which one of us would not have
done that who's the one person because i
know one of you were who's the one
person that didn't want to see these
three guys in a movie together but for
toby tom and andrew you're welcome
and so i guess let's really cut to the
big question that a lot of people have
right what was the big post-credits
scene because we knew before this film
came out even though there were rumors
and we didn't know for certain that
there was basically a post-credits scene
that was in the film that was not in the
original theatrical release well the
cool thing about this is this actually
shows us how far reaching the effects
are of the spell that was cast to remove
everyone's knowledge of tom holland's
peter parker from existence and so what
happens in this post-credits scene is
betty brant who plays the school
reporter in midtown high is basically
showing a montage of various scenes and
clips and images and things like that
from essentially all the previous movies
that we'd seen and tom holland's peter
parker is nowhere to be seen in any of
those and so all the indications from
this post-credits scene seem to point to
the idea that every trace of peter's
existence every image every video the
whole nine yards he simply just isn't
there so it's not as though the way we
originally suspected in the post-credits
scene when the movie first came out that
simply his memory of his existence was
removed from everyone's minds every
trace of his existence was removed and
honestly i feel like some variation of
this should have been put in the
original film otherwise we wouldn't have
been asking this question in the first
place but this really seems to solidify
that that it's not simply that people
forgot peter parker it's as though he
never existed but the next deleted scene
we get into is a scene that features
harry holland the brother of tom holland
which was originally cut from the film
and actually disappointed both tom and
harry because of something that they
really really wanted to see but this
scene basically features harry holland
snatching a purse and then running
spider-man of course catches up to him
he strings him up on his webs and then
it's basically some banter i mean it's
people saying everything from reasonable
statements to just ridiculous statements
for example somebody says something
along the lines that teen brains are not
as developed as adult brains therefore
he's not equipped to be able to decide
who is a criminal and who is not and
even one person says something is
ridiculous is the fact that peter and
criminals are actually working in
cahoots and peter of course gives a
sarcastic reaction and saying no yeah
i'm working with him like that kind of a
thing which in all honesty that's a
funny little reference to the comics
because in the early days of
spider-man's adventures one of the
things that jay jonah jameson had put
forward is the idea that peter parker
and criminals were working together the
peter was actually making it possible or
giving criminals ideas for crimes that
peter would in turn swoop in and
basically stop them from committing in
order to guarantee his own reason and
success in the superhero landscape it's
ridiculous but it's still kind of cool
now the next deleted scene that we get
is the one where peter basically has his
interrogation scene with damage control
and this one's not overly important it
basically just gives more of the
interrogation from peter's perspective
so he talks about climbing the various
monuments we'd seen him climb in the
previous film and in fact they even
interrogate him a little bit more about
the whole night monkey persona that he
had for a little while but it just kind
of is a nice way to bring in some of his
previous actions from the other films is
it overly important no but it's still
kind of cool now the next deleted scene
that we get is one that focuses on happy
hogan damage control and matt murdock
also known as daredevil who we're all
very very excited to see in future mcu
projects and this one actually sort of
pigtails off of an existing scene that
we saw in the promos which was all the
villains just kind of awkwardly riding
up the escalator or the elevator rather
to happy hogan's apartment but when they
get there happy hogan is basically
dealing with damage control alongside
his attorney matt murdock now this scene
unfolds pretty much the way you would
expect it to with him being asked
various questions and interrogation
style and so on and so forth but there
is a moment very similar to the first
scene that we got in the movie with matt
murdock when he caught the brick if you
guys recall and i don't know why you
wouldn't somebody threw a brick through
the window and then matt murdock caught
it and spiderman was like how in the
hell did you catch that it's similar to
that in the sense that matt murdock
tells happy hogan to stop sweating even
though happy hogan is not visibly
sweating and so it's basically matt
murdock's senses picking up on the fact
that happy hogan is sweating even though
it can't really be discerned by the
naked eye now this is kind of a cool
little way to sort of segue into the
powers of matt murdock the fact that
he's able to use his enhanced senses to
detect things that people normally
wouldn't be able to pick up on it's not
the most important scene there ever was
but as far as daredevil goes it does add
a bit of expansion to what we already
know or have already seen about his
powers at least from daredevil and the
first spider-man no way home release and
what it is that he's capable of which i
love these small little touches i like
seeing these small little things
regarding matt murdock and what it is
that he's able to do given the various
powers that he has but there's another
deleted scene which is kind of like
peter's day at school kind of to a
degree but what it basically shows is
that people
while his identity is ousted to the
world and people know who he is they
kind of blend the line between treating
him like he's some kind of a freak and
then wanting him to do spider-man stuff
so they have them like crawl up walls
and things like that and then just keep
referring to him as a freak which is
kind of weird so they sort of split the
difference i don't know how overly
important this scene was and i'm not too
upset that it was removed from the movie
it was interesting but it wasn't really
necessary here's the reason why it
probably got cut in the first place but
probably one of the better scenes that
in all honesty i feel like should have
been included in the original theatrical
release but i can understand why it was
cut just simply due to timing is the
extended scene of the three spiderman
hanging out which was really really
amazing so you guys remember that scene
when the three of them were hanging out
and you get a smidgen of a conversation
about the bio webbing of toby it's
basically that right it's a little bit
of an extension of that and in fact they
kind of talk about the different things
they've done right the instance where
tom holland went into space in order to
stop thanos the instance where toby
mcguire is talking about having defeated
an alien symbiote obviously referring to
venom and then of course andrew garfield
didn't really do anything cool in his
spider-man movies except like when stacy
die and i don't even know if that's a
cool thing but that was really kind of
his moment to essentially sulk in the
scene and that's when he gets a bit of a
pick-me-up from toby mcguire who tells
him dude you're amazing right you can't
keep dumping on yourself or you have to
look at the things you've done and
simply just tell yourself you just
haven't reached the moment where you
fought a symbiote or something along
those lines so it's a cool instance to
see these characters relating in that
way and then of course as we know from
the various leaks and rumors that have
come out the statements made that we
should all do this again sometime and
then it's definitely so what this seems
to indicate is that for these three guys
andrew toby tom that it doesn't look
like we're simply going to see them
walking away and never reuniting again
which makes perfect sense and in fact we
have a video about that which will show
up here or here one of those places but
basically it'll be a video talking about
these three different spider-man and how
they could return with regards to the
larger spider-verse series of movies
that sony's making into the spider-verse
beyond spider-verse and how they're
seemingly building up to a giant
spider-verse-centric event that could
see these three spider-man and others
that we haven't seen yet or have seen
all reuniting to face off against some
common foe wouldn't it be awesome if the
entire spider-verse reunited to face off
and help the avengers and whoever else
defeat king the conqueror that would be
a massive event let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
though have you guys seen the re-release
or have you guys not seen the re-release
and if you haven't seen it let me know
why i'm kind of curious but thank you
all for watching and we will catch you
all later
peace